at the latest Council EU Agriculture and
fishery ministers reach political
agreement on next year's fishing
opportunities in the Baltic Sea
confirming how many fish from the main
commercial species can be caught in the
Baltic Sea in 2015.
the proposed limits have been
established according to Scientific
advice and taking into account the new
Landing obligation for stocks such as
Cod Herring and salmon
ministers also acknowledged that the
Russian embargo on EU fishing products
will have consequences on the management
of some of those fish stocks
the council also discussed the impact of
the Russian ban on Imports of EU
agricultural products
While most member states recognize the
appropriateness of the commission's
emergency measures on fruit and
vegetables in the milk sector some of
the country's most affected call for
additional support to mitigate the price
losses
the council also took stock of the
situation regarding African swine fever
in the EU which is affecting domestic
pigs in Lithuania Poland Latvia and
Estonia
on the agricultural sector's
contribution to the midterm review of
the Europe 2020 strategy ministers noted
that the new cap has the potential to
help achieve the sustainable growth
Targets in particular through rural
development measures to maintain jobs in
rural areas and to make them more
attractive to young people
foreign